im hessischen Burghaun im Ortsteil
schlotzau saniert die Gemeinde das
Dorfgemeinschaftshaus und baut direkt
daneben ein neues Feuerwehrhaus seit
zehn Jahren wird an beidem
herumgewerkelt stolze 850.000 Euro haben
Sanierungen und Neubau mittlerweile
gekostet doch die Verwaltung bekommt
ihre Dauerbaustelle nicht fertig
privat hätte so niemand gebaut und wenn
dann wäre heute pleite das ist einfach
so es wurde dann halt immer irgendwie
was neues entschieden oder was anderes
entschieden und allein schon die ganze
Planung wie lang sich das dann in
Wirklichkeit hingezogen hat
2013 beginnen die Bauarbeiten ans alte
Dorfgemeinschaftshaus wird eine neue
Fahrzeughalle angebaut doch beim
Innenausbau passiert jahrelang nichts es
gibt keine Schulungsräume deshalb muss
der Unterricht auch im Winter mit
Heizlüfter hinter dem Einsatzfahrzeug
stattfinden aber nicht nur das in einem
Schacht in dem eigentlich die Fernwärme
ankommen soll steht Wasser
die Abflussrinne daneben ist nicht
angeschlossen und das Hauptproblem
ausgerechnet beim Gebäude der Feuerwehr
gibt seit Jahren Fehler beim Brandschutz
unglaublich
es nervt langsam so ein bisschen dass
das Gerätehaus nicht übergeben wird und
das ist halt immer noch in der Bauphase
ist kein fertiges Feuerwehrhaus das
Dorfgemeinschaftshaus eine
Dauerbaustelle nicht nutzbar für die
Bürger das ist eben sehr schade für so
ein Dorfleben weil es lebt eben von
Veranstaltungen von Gemeinschaft und wir
haben jetzt hier die Problematik dass
eben ja dass diese Werte eben in dem
Dorf langsam verschwinden der neue
Bürgermeister hat das Bau Desaster vom
Vorgänger übernommen die schier endlose
Bauzeit kann er nicht erklären ich habe
aber immer drauf verzichtet da Fehler
oder Schuldige zu suchen Lösungen sucht
keine Schuldigen
den einen Schuldigen gibt es an dieser
Stelle auch nicht das muss man
fairerweise auch dazu sagen
Antworten die den Feuerwehrleuten nicht
mehr reichen
wenn ich so arbeiten würde und hier so
flickweg teilweise habt das könnte ich
so an der Arbeit nicht stehen lassen
weil will ja mal fertig werden und man
will mal wieder was was machen wir
wollen wieder Mitglieder werden wie soll
man das in dem Stadium hier versuchen
die Liste der Baumängel wächst weiter
jetzt ist das Dach des
Dorfgemeinschaftshauses undicht muss neu
gedeckt werden der Bürgermeister
verspricht ein schnelles Ende der
Bauarbeiten doch daran glauben die
Feuerwehrleute längst nicht mehr